je redire ici je vous avais l'air
d'écarter monsieur anodin d'Arona les
parents c'est un rôle essentiel bien sûr
si on met pas la responsabilité des
débuts sur les premiers responsables on
n'y arrive pas alors il y a beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont dit mais les parents ils
sont pour rien moi j'ai été élevé il me
semble dans beaucoup d'ici entre entre
nous j'ai pas fait des bêtises il y a
des parents qui m'ont rappelé et quand
le prof ou le policier me faisait de
remontrances j'en prenais une à la
maison voilà et donc je pense que il
faut redire quelle serait les pistes
alors ce que je vous dis moi je pense
qu'il faut généraliser les expulsions
par exemple des logements sociaux des
familles à problèmes on en connait tous
des familles à problèmes je confonds pas
avec la dame seul qu'elle aime ses trois
gamins qui est très difficile pour elle
d'avoir un ado de turbulent là on doit
l'aider on n'est pas là pour lui
rajouter des problèmes mais il y a des
familles qui vivent des problèmes dont
on sait que l'ensemble de la famille vit
de vol de trafic de drogue mais le
bordel dans le quartier pardon de dire
autrement on peut pas continuer à donner
un logement social à ces gens